you saw Brad at because I know a Kanye
had his the service yeah he did he was
there he I think he's been a couple
times but that was the first time that I
was there when he was there and I
literally left early well it turns out
even Kendall Jenner gets starstruck and
honestly do we blame her I just saw once
upon a time in Hollywood and it was so
good and he just like gets better with
age like I gotta go yeah Kendall
literally left Sunday service early
because she couldn't handle it like why
you didn't want to meet him no because
isn't there a saying like don't ever
meet your superhero whatever I don't
know I just like love him so much I'm
like I'm just gonna leave it at that Wow
complete naked nerd and honestly I've
never related more now if you missed the
news about Brad and Kanye here's a small
refresher
yep that's Brad at Kanye's service
earlier this month at the time a source
told et that Brad was quote just amazed
by the atmosphere and love and that he
made sure to take as many pictures
everyone who asked during Kendall
Thursday appearance on The Tonight Show
she also said she wants to set Brad up
with Rihanna I think Brad Pitt and
Rihanna that would be I feel like come
on but you felt gorgeous one tiny
problem Rihanna has been dating her
billionaire businessman boyfriend Hasan
Jamil for a while now kendall also gave
us an update on Kim's fourth baby psalm
revealing she actually helped him pick
out the name she would not let me leave
the house until we figured out a name
Bria and then ended up going with the
name isn't even like that I didn't care
for as much like I think they were all
really beautiful but I was like I was
kind of rooting for anything no word on
what that other name was but we do know
psalm has a special meaning the
inspiration was the Book of Psalms in
the Bible so I think it's just a
wonderful way to celebrate you know how
they feel
he's such a blessing so it's perfect
alright that's it for today for all the
latest on Kendall and the Kardashians
make sure that you keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]